ahora que ya tenemos una parametrización
para la frontera de nuestra superficie
de aquí arriba vamos a pensar un poco en
la integral de línea que estaba a la
izquierda de nuestro enunciado original
del teorema de stocks esencialmente el
lado izquierdo tenía la integral a lo
largo de una curva sé que es la frontera
de nuestra superficie del campo
vectorial efe punto de r donde está de
repusiera
venía de la parametrización es la
diferencial de nuestra función r que
parametrizar la curvas y recordemos
quiénes f
se estaba dado al inicio del problema
aquí está por el campo vectorial que
tiene como entradas a pq y ere que son
funciones de x de iu y de zeta entonces
ya habiendo recordado todo esto vámonos
esencialmente a lo que queremos bueno
recordemos quién es primero de r porque
de r es no es otra cosa más que la
derivada de r respecto de t por de t ok
esto nos permite pasar la integral de
línea a una integral sobre la región de
los del parámetro t que esencialmente se
mueve entre a y b entonces nada más
veamos entonces quién es la derivada de
r con respecto de t
porque esto simplemente es derivar cada
una de las entradas respecto de t
entonces tenemos la la derivada de x la
derivada de x respecto de t en la
primera coordenada más la derivada de g
respecto de t en la segunda coordenada
más y aquí esto puede ser un poquito más
complicado porque z depende de xy de ya
que a la vez cada una de ellas dependen
de t entonces tenemos que pensar
realmente en todas las formas en las que
z puede cambiar respecto de t entonces
déjenme déjenme hacerlo de la siguiente
forma la derivada de z con respecto de t
simplemente lo podemos ver bueno cómo
puede cambiar respecto de este cambiando
primero respecto de x verdad entonces
esto sería la parcial la parcial de zeta
respecto de x
la derivada de x respecto de t también
puede cambiar respecto de t al variar
respecto desde entonces esto será la
parcial de z respecto de y por la
derivada de y respecto de t esto no es
otra cosa más que la regla de la cadena
en varias variables verdad entonces ya
que tenemos esto aquí podemos sumar el
es la derivada de 7 respecto de t
entonces hay que sumar selo a esta
expresión y multiplicarlo por nuestro
vector acá pero voy a hacerlo con una
anotación que que coincide un poquito
más con lo que estamos haciendo aquí
arriba
y ya no lo encuentro era aquí estaba no
las derivadas respecto de xy de que lo
vamos a poner como subíndices entonces
esto será la derivada de zeta respecto
de x por la derivada de x respecto de t
más la derivada de zeta respecto de y
por la derivada de y respecto de t y
todo esto multiplica a nuestro vector
está ok entonces esto es la diferencial
de r multiplicada bueno más bien esta
derivada al multiplicarlo por la
diferencial de t nos da la diferencial
de r que es justamente la que queremos
calcular aquí entonces vamos a
reescribir esto vamos a reescribir esto
porque ya al pasarlo
en términos de los parámetros tendremos
la integral sobre la región de los
parámetros que simplemente es el
intervalo a ver porque te se mueve entre
a y b ok de bueno recordemos también que
f
nuestro campo vectorial efe simplemente
es la función p en la primera coordenada
más la función como en la segunda
coordenada más r en la tercera
coordenada entonces si hacemos el
producto df con de r simplemente será el
producto de este de este vector con este
otro y multiplicamos por de t entonces
tendremos p que multiplica
derivada
derivada de x con respecto de t más
que multiplica a la derivada de y voy a
ponerlo con el mismo color la derivada
de y con respecto de t
y aquí es en donde viene la parte
interesante porque vamos a multiplicar
r&r por esta otra parte ok por z x la
derivada de x respecto de t más detalle
que multiplica la derivada de y respecto
de t y todo esto hay que multiplicarlo
por la diferencial de t correcto
entonces ahí los voy a dejar en este
vídeo solo porque tenemos llegar a hacer
algunos errores así que lo que haremos
ahora es reacomodar toda esta cosa y
reconocer que que esta última parte que
obtuvimos en en vídeos anteriores nos da
una forma en la que podemos aplicar el
teorema de greene usándolo en la
frontera c1 que es la que encierra a la
región r y luego haremos más
manipulaciones algebraicas para ver que
está integrada al final se simplifica a
lo que queríamos demostrar inicialmente
y que es igual a esta expresión